Bowers: Thanks, Kevin.
[applause]
So I'm gonna walk you
through a quick tour
of what it's like
to develop an app
on the App Engine SDK for Java.
And in the spirit of our
birthday and our demo last year,
I'm gonna do that in the context
of a very simple
guestbook application.
So, this application, uh,
if you were here last year,
you remember we simply
enter in a post.
We'll, uh, just say,
"Hello Campfire One."
And this is going to--
uh, it's a simple HTML form.
It's going to post
to a servlet.
Save that to the data store,
redirect back,
and then list out the entries
in the data store.
So, I'm gonna walk you through
what it's like
to develop that app.
So, first I'm gonna
go over to Eclipse.
Now, this is a popular
open-source ID
with Java developers,
so it probably looks
familiar to many of you.
I've got the standard
Java perspective here,
but you'll notice
the icons in the top left.
As Kevin mentioned, we provided
support for Google Web Toolkit
and for App Engine,
so it's gonna make tasks
like project creation
and deployment to App Engine
a lot easier.
Now I'm going to
create a new project
by clicking
on the blue icon, top-left.
That brings up
the new project wizard,
and I'm gonna enter
in a project name and a package.
So, I'm gonna
call it "Guestbook,"
and I'll enter the same package.
Now, I could use Google
Web Toolkit or App Engine,
and this is going to configure
my starter project.
I'm not gonna use any Ajax
for this very simple demo,
so I'm just gonna uncheck that,
and I'll click "Finish."
This has now created
the starter project.
And it's a standard
J2EE servlet project.
This project right now,
I could take,
I could go run it
on another servlet container.
If we look inside,
you'll see a source directory,
as you'd expect.
That's where our Java files go.
Our App Engine SDK
and the JRE onto my machine.
And then a web archive
or WAR directory.
So App Engine uses the standard
Java web archive layout
as its deployment directory.
You're gonna put all your
JSPs, your static files,
your class files
into this directory,
and that's what's going to get
deployed up to App Engine.
Now, if you look inside this
servlet that's created for me,
you'll a see very simple,
standard servlet,
takes an http request
and prints out "Hello, world."
So now I've got the--
the project here,
and I wanna get started.
Well, if you've ever had
a great idea for a project
and you wanted to go ahead
and start developing something,
and then you spend a day
trying to set up a local server,
you're probably going to be
happy with App Engine SDK.
App Engine ships
with a local development server
with the SDK,
so you simply download it,
and you can
get started right away.
So, what I do is right-click
on my project.
I'll go to "Debug As"...
"Web Application."
This is going to
start up the local server.
It mimics
the production environment.
So any restrictions we have
on Java classes
in the production environment
are also going to be
reflected in the local server.
So, now I'm started
on local host 80 80,
so if I go over,
and let's open up a new tab.
And I'll go to that servlet url.
And I get "Hello, world."
As we'd expect.
So, now I can go
and I can start iterating here,
and continue with the theme.
I could say, "Campfire One."
Save my changes,
and I'll see
my changes reflected.
So, I've got the basis
for the project,
the foundation there,
and I wanna start
layering on this,
uh, this guestbook application.
Lemme take a--take you through
what the architecture, uh--
if you can call three files
an "architecture"--looks like.
So, if we can bring up
the architecture.
So, I have a--
[laughter]
A, uh, uh--
this is very complicated.
If you get lost
just let me know.
I have, uh, guestbook jsp.
That's going to
post to a servlet.
That servlet creates
this Entry.java object.
It's gonna save that
to our datastore,
redirect back to our jsp.
The jsp is then going to
query the datastore
for the list of entries we have
and display that on the page.
Now, in order
not to bore you and save time,
I've written a lot of
the post logic and the jsp logic
and I'm gonna
drag those into the--
into the project now.
Uh, gotta find my mouse, here.
So, lemme do that.
Just go ahead and turn that off.
So I'm gonna drag the Java files
into my source directory.
And we'll overwrite
the existing servlet.
I'll drag the guestbook jsp...
into my web archive directory.
And now, as Kevin mentioned,
we're using standards, uh--
standard web XML
as a configuration file.
And, um, since I just
drug in this guestbook jsp
I don't want people
to have to remember that jsp,
so I'm gonna go
into the web XML.
You notice it's
in that web inf directory.
And I'll just change the welcome
file to be guestbook.
Save that there.
And so now, let's go ahead
and try to run this locally.
Make sure that I did bring in
all the files I meant to.
So I should just be able
to go to that url.
And so now I've got
the jsp there.
So the next thing I wanna do is
actually saved to the datastore.
As Kevin mentioned, App Engine
is built on top of Big Table,
which is distributed storage
platform that's scalable.
It's the--it's what we use
here at Google.
Um, in addition to the low-level
APIs that talk to Big Table,
we've also implemented
standard space APIs
in the form of Java data objects
and Java persistence API.
So JDO and JPA,
if you've ever used them before,
allow you to persist standard
Java objects to a datastore.
And they're datastore agnostic,
so that means they work
with Sequel databases,
they work
with file systems, XML,
or in our case,
the App Engine datastore.
And what that means is that
I could take code
that I've written
in, uh--for JDO or JPA, and I
could run it on another system,
say, a system that uses
Sequel as a back-in.
Now, in this case,
I'm going to use JDO,
and I wanna persist
the entry Java class
to my datastore.
So, if I look inside this class,
you'll see that I have
some fields that store content
and who's posting.
Just a very simple constructor
and then some
getters and setters.
In order to store this,
what I need to do
is annotate it
with JDO annotation.
So I'll do that.
First thing I wanna do
is add an annotation
that tells the datastore
that this class
can actually be persisted.
And then I wanna specify
its application level.
Next thing I'm gonna do
is specify which fields
I wanna store.
And I'll do that
for all the fields.
And then lastly, every object
in JDO needs a primary key,
so I wanna set that.
I'll set it on the I.D. up here.
And then I want the datastore
to generate that I.D. for me
as well.
So, now I have
all the annotations I need
to store this object
to the datastore.
Next thing I wanna do
is I wanna go to the servlet
and actually store that.
So, we'll go take a look there.
So, here's the servlet.
You can see that
I'm getting the post parameters,
then creating that entry object.
And the next thing I wanna do
is save it to the datastore.
Now, JDO uses something
called Persistence Manager
to interact with the datastore.
And it uses a factory pattern,
uh, with a
Persistence Manager Factory
to get that Persistence Manager.
Uh, there--it's analogous
to a database connection pool,
and there's a little bit
of overhead associated with it,
so we wanna be efficient
and use a Singleton incidence.
And I've actually, uh,
done that code as well,
and I'm gonna drag that in.
If we look inside,
you can see
just getting that
Persistence Manager Factory.
So, now I go back here, and...
I'll get a Persistence Manager
from that.
Next thing I wanna do
is I want to persist the object
by calling "make persistent."
And then finally
close out the connection.
So, this is gonna save
the object to the datastore,
and then you can see the
redirecting back to guestbook.
So, let's go to guestbook
and now list out the entries.
Or guestbook jsp.
So, you can see,
js--standard jsp file.
I'll go down
to the bottom here.
And you can see
I have a list of entries,
and because I'm a clumsy typer
I took the easy way out
and I've commented the code.
So I'm just gonna
walk you through that.
So, the first thing
I'm going to do is get
a Persistence Manager again,
to interact with the datastore.
Next thing I'll do
is I'll create a query.
Very similar to Sequel
with the syntax,
so I say, "select from"--
Lemme make this bigger
so you can see it.
I say, "select from,"
I specify which objects,
and then I specify any
filtering or ordering criteria.
And then the last thing
I'm going to do
is populate that list
by executing the query.
So that should be
our database code.
Let's go ahead
and try to run this.
So, running again
on local host 80 80.
We'll refresh for good measure.
So, now the jsp
posted to the servlet,
created that entry object,
saved it to the datastore,
and listed it out.
A killer app, for sure.
[laughter]
Uh, so now I wanna
share it with the world.
So, uh--so that--
so that all my friends can see.
The way I'm gonna do that--
I'm gonna go back to Eclipse
and deploy it out to App Engine.
So, first thing I'll do
is go back here--
And you'll see there's a little
App Engine icon in the top left.
I'm gonna click on that,
and you'll notice
there's an error here right now.
It's because I haven't set
an application I.D. for this.
Every app on App Engine
needs a, uh--an application I.D.
A unique application I.D,
so I'm gonna go
to my project settings.
And then I'll go over
to the App Engine console
and actually set that.
So, I'm gonna create
a new application I.D.,
and we'll call it
"campfire guestbook."
And if you're trying
to beat me to it,
uh, that would be a way to--
It would be a way to trip me up.
Please don't.
[audience chuckles]
Okay, so we registered
that I.D. successfully.
So, I'm gonna go back
and set that.
All I have to do now is enter in
my username and password.
And then I click "Deploy."
And that's it.
So, the SDK is compiling,
uh, my Java source code,
packaging everything up,
and sending it up to the server.
So, now it says
it's deployed successfully.
So I can go over here.
And I now have
an application on the web.
[applause]
And we'll just
make sure it works.
So, if you ever had an idea
for an application
and you wanted to actually
go and implement it,
and you only had a weekend,
um, and you were
probably thwarted
because you took a week
to get it out,
this is a solution that I think
you're gonna be
really happy with.
I've just created a--
a whole Java application,
albeit very simple,
and deployed it to the web
in, you know, a matter
of 10 or 15 minutes.
Um, not only that,
we also were using standard APIs
and Java-standard APIs, um,
for the datastore
and for the other APIs.
So I could take that code,
and I could also run it
on any other server as well.
Thanks.
Hand it back to you, Kevin.
[applause]